und
[Musik]
das hier ist echt zu einer meiner
favoriten
bora bora
[Musik]
hallo zusammen heute machen wir einen
viralen trend also eigentlich habe ich
finde wenn man schon sehr oft gemacht
aber irgendwie geht es gerade viral es
gibt in köln einladen der heißt sinne
mut und ich wollte da auch gerne mal hin
aber ich habe bis jetzt noch nicht
geschafft und ich habe mir gedacht als
auch die selbst gegangen bin ich sagt
warum stehen die leute schlange klar
sind schnecken sind geil diesem lecker
aber was ist das besondere und dann hab
ich so gelesen gefüllt mit pistazien
creme gefüllt mit schokocreme und dann
habe ich mir gedacht ein - hallo kriens
und so da sind wir am mega aufgestellt
warum sollte ich das nicht selber machen
das bietet sich perfekt an und ich würde
direkt loslegen also machen wir heute
die gehalten sinne man findet in bands
von seinem mut sagt ich habe euch alle
ganz genauen mengenangaben hier unten in
die infobox aufgeschrieben könnte
einfach aufklappen screen schotten und
das ganze machen und ich habe jetzt
einen tipp für euch ich habe jetzt hier
das komplette mehl in eine schüssel ich
nehme heute die küchenmaschine es geht
aber auch wunderbar per hand das seht
ihr in meinem anderen zungen man rezepte
habe ich auch schoko segment bands
gemacht verlinkt ich euch auch in der
infobox ich würde jetzt hier von einfach
mal so ein bisschen was rausnehmen weil
je nachdem wie viel volumen die eier
haben braucht die vielleicht so weniger
an mail bis sie meist immer gerne so
dass ich von der gesamtmenge mail ein
bisschen was zur seite legen und dann im
nachgang mehr zu geben und ich arbeite
heute mit trockenhefe gibt also die
trockenhefe direkt zum mehl dann können
da auch schon das kann er noch dazu
zucker kann schon betreiben denn für
ruhig da kurz miteinander und dann
kommen eigentlich auch schon die
flüssigen zutaten mit rein da habe ich
nur lauwarme milch die verbindet sich
einfach besser und butter die ich in der
mikrowelle verlassen habe und dann dass
ich das ganze kurz kneten und gibt dann
auch schon die eier mit rein
[Musik]
für den letzten zwei minuten knete ich
dann doch immer gerne mit der hand weil
ich finde dann hat man einfach ein
besseres gefühl dafür und ich glaube ich
brauche heute sogar ist komplette mail
und danach für mich ist einfach zu einer
kugel also der teig kubala der teig darf
jetzt nicht zu fest sein aber auch nicht
zu klebrig ich sage mal sollte sich
anfühlt wie ohrläppchen dann könnt ihr
euch nicht vor angeboten darin könnt ihr
euch auf jeden fall orientieren und wer
war denn von euch schon mal weiß seine
mode also ich war noch nicht obwohl es
in köln ist das ist von mir ungefähr 40
minuten ich wollte immer weil das so
extrem lecker aussieht aber wir haben es
noch nicht geschafft aber was nicht ist
kann ja noch werden und wenn ihr noch
weitere geheime leben kennen dann
schreibt sie mir noch gerne in die
kommentare dann würde ich mir auch gerne
mal anschauen
[Musik]
der teig konnte jetzt bei mir 30 minuten
gehen wenn derzeit habe gerne auf 45
minuten aber da ist schon richtig
aufgegangen und ich werde jetzt erst mal
die hälfte des tages bearbeiten also
nehme ich jetzt einfach nach augenmaß
die hälfte weg und die andere hälfte
packe ich wieder zurück ich werde
übrigens sechs verschiedene varianten
machen und habe dann von jeder variante
quasi
44 röhrchen und
als erstes werden wir den teig aber mal
ausbreiten ungefähr 44 x 32 cm es müsste
ich so genau nehmen ich weiß aber aus
meinen anderen videos dass es immer
hilfreich ist wenn ihr so eine angabe
habt dafür nehme ich mir gleich mein aus
neustadt breite das aus und dann zeige
ich euch wie es weitergeht
[Musik]
zu den ausgebreiteten teig müssen wir
jetzt erstmal durch drei teil für jede
sorte eine partie dann nehme ich immer
ungefähr 14 zentimeter oder ihr schaut
einfach nach augenmaß das ist jetzt bei
mir immer so ungefähr eine teig eine
kleine teig karte breit ich kann mir das
hier auch schon mal ein zeichen mit
meinem pizzerien und stefan messer sagt
so was habe ich jetzt einmal durch drei
geteilt und diese drei teile werden dann
nochmal durch vier geteilt weil jede
sorte bekommt ihr 40 wobei ich ja gar
keinen cent drauf machen müsste ich die
anders nennen kann ich sie sonst nennen
ich weiß es kann ich halte man die
kommentare habt ihr ein fälle so und
dann werde ich hier habe ich gesagt ja
genau also am besten macht es so dass
jetzt immer ein teilnehmen und mit eurer
lieblings creme bestreicht ich nehme
jetzt hier zuallererst die haselnuss
creme und da habe ich mir sogar überlegt
ob ich nicht obendrauf nach gehackte
haselnüsse gerne darauf macht das
natürlich euch überlassen aber dann hat
man auch noch ein bisschen was zu beißen
das ist ein moment
einmal goldene folie ab und dann so
bestreichen dass ihr vorne ungefähr
eineinhalb zentimeter platz last weil
wenn ihr das nach vorne rollt gefällt
euch sonst ein bisschen was raus und
dann werde ich wie gesagt dass dann noch
mal durch vier teilen weil wir immer
viel pro sorte haben
[Musik]
also ich hab jetzt wie schon erwähnt
hier eröffnen mit der hazel cream
begonnen ich habe auch noch gehackte
haselnüsse dazu getan bei der zweiten
variante habe ich dann unsere pistazien
creme genommen und auch noch mal sagte
pistazien und top gegeben und die dritte
variante ist jetzt hier die spekulation
mit ein paar
spekulation und top und das ganze wird
einfach aufgerollt und dann gesagt durch
vier geteilt wenn ihr mehr glück ist es
euch doch ein bisschen zu klein könnt
ihr das auch durch drei teilen es ist
auch kein problem
[Musik]
so ich hab mir jetzt ein blech geholt
und das schon mal ordentlich ein
gebuttert und jetzt kommen schon mal die
sorten auf blech natürlich mit der
schönen seite nach oben
und dann müsste natürlich die andere
hälfte des bleches nochmal freilassen
weil da kommt der jetzt die andere
hälfte des tages das werde ich genauso
machen wie jetzt auch hier mit diesen
röllchen ich werde das einfach
ausbreiten dann mit drei füllungen
bestreichen und diesmal bei der zweiten
hälfte nehme ich auf jeden fall eine
kokos füllung dann nehme ich eine schoko
führung doch mal was fruchtiges sieht er
lade in der sorte himbeere mal was
richtiges darf meiner meinung nach nicht
fehlen und danach wenn ihr das alles
soweit habt auch noch mal schön abdecken
und 30 minuten gehen lassen wir dann
werden sie so richtig fluffig also ich
merke ich schon der teig ist schon
extrem lustig und wie gut das aussieht
der pistazien creme also der ist schon
richtig richtig flüssig aber diese
zweite gehzeit die reist noch mal alles
raus dann werden sie auch schon gebacken
[Musik]
so die waren wir zum backofen 180 grad
ober und unterhitze und die brauchen 25
minuten und ich wünschte ich wünsche dir
könnte das riechen es riecht so krank
einfach so viele gerüche die einfach
genial ich noch einmal und jetzt geht's
ans dekorieren wir brauchen natürlich
noch einen topping und dafür nehme ich
auch wieder die ganzen creams und
natürlich auch lucia lade und gibt das
einfach und ob ihr habt ihr gerade die
konsistenz gesehen und ihr könnt meine
krems bei 900 watt oder bei 614 bis 12
14 sekunden also nicht so lange in die
mikrowelle tun damit sie so ein bisschen
cremiger und flüssiger werden aber
eigentlich und manchmal mit hesl
anfangen
eigentlich reicht er hier auch die
restwärme von den hefe banque syz ich
gebe jetzt einfach die creme so wie sie
ist und ob
dann müsste sie wegen der restwärme doch
auch das funktioniert also könnt ihr
euch den schritt mit der mikrowelle
sogar sparen das sieht richtig gut aus
und dann würde ich einfach nur noch
dekorieren immer das woran ich die
criminale tier denke ich an bruno weil
die station macht auch noch pistazien
und ob dann das habe ich hier das musste
ich spekuliere seiner comics und raphael
los und so weiter also dekorierte
einfach nach herzenslust ich könnte
gleich auf jeden fall noch mal
süßigkeiten schrank
[Musik]
nein
also falls ihr jetzt auch lust bekommen
habt auf diese fluffigen teilchen die
sind ja wirklich extrem fluffig dann
macht sie unbedingt nach und wenn ihr
sie am nächsten tag noch wissen möchtet
dann einfach nur für ein paar sekunden
in der mikrowelle geben und sie
schmecken wieder super frisch also ich
wünsche euch viel spaß und nachmachen
eventuell sind die gleichsam einen test
mit hamza aber ich verabschiede mich
offiziell an der stelle und abonniert
main kanal wenn ihr das nicht schon
längst getan habt dann verpasst ihr
solch genialen rezepte auch nicht mehr
und dann würde ich mal sagen bis zu
einem nächsten videothek
dazu gekriegt ja ich hab ich hatte nicht
mehr die motivation wir ein vernünftiges
oberteil und jeans oder anzug zum blog
effekt also wir probleme jetzt unsere
crazy szene bands die nicht zu tun haben
aber ich muss sagen ich war fertig doch
gewinnt nach dem folgenreichen oder der
computer machen kannst du welche
programm ich gebe dass ich es kann
losgehen dann haben sie haben sich aber
ganz ehrlich hallo mit dingen was bietet
kriegt einfach nur da sein einfach geil
so kommen für sowas kommt sogar
schwimmen
du hast oder war hier ich habe auch
gehört auch das kribbeln und ich lege
ich habe aus versehen spekulation nicht
mit den die mikrowelle tatsächlich hatte
in der mikrowelle erwärmen aber du
kannst dich kennen
okay
die nähere oder nicht so gleichzeitig
ist das ist
ein traum ein traum
das ist sie also dieser test ist kann
jetzt kann sich um stunden handeln ist
alles durchprobieren
das mandat ist in amerika freundliches
wort wirkt er ist doch wohin und ich
nehme mein favorit ist dass das ist der
kick ass crm hazel ja okay ich sage auch
viele es schmeckt wie das innere von
giotto und dann wieder um seine ziele
wie boeing oder fifty-fifty aber ich
finde ich mit videos von giotto jetzt
intensive schmeckt
also geil vom aussehen und geschmack
auch überlegt wohin das während oben
folgen die uns direkt nehmen vor leute
diese distanz ins leben geschmeckt
heftig bei normalen cinema und was macht
man ja butter drauf und zucker und hier
braucht man das sind alles gar nicht
dann bin ich nur die krebs drauf
geschmiert die
krebse die creme neuer hier ist schön
hier bei storkow und bei wohl nur habe
ich auch noch hasen ist kern im film
anderes zu beißen find ich ja auch geil
das hier ist echt zu einer meiner
favoriten max marck schmeckt richtig gut
schmecken richtig heftig wenn es nach
gemacht habt ach so groß ist und kehrte
bis jetzt wenig später auf das gemüse
kam jemand vergessen aber es ist schon
sehr warm dass seine fraktion sekunden
da hatte ich fünf stück für eine minute
ein und dass man jetzt 15 sekunden und
man merkt
also es schmeckt auch am nächsten tag
noch aber übernächsten bregenz nicht
messen das ist einen tag vor
auch gut
so
kastenhofer ich geblieben ist der
konzernchef selbst vier zähler ich hätte
nicht gedacht das ist dass diese
fruchtige note so lecker schmeckt auch
heftig und ich wusste schon dass der
fruchtig und hefeteig geht immer was
machen die leute jetzt genauer diese
krebs kaufen
da machen leute dass ich mich echt
heftig wirklich nachmachen wird ist
nicht angeboren verteilt das ist nämlich
auch echt fielen also es läuft gerade
die champions league match ist dagegen
die rhema trips es ist halbzeit und
langgezogen hier aber ist so schlimm das
ist vergangen
jetzt
ja bildern weg
[Musik]